à demain si vous le voulez bien non ce
n'est pas la fin de ce journal mais le
célèbre au revoir de lucia jeunesse qui
pendant 30 ans sur france inter a animé
le jeu des 1000 francs et lance dans
quelques jours cet au revoir sera le
dernier
lucien prend sa retraite mais garde sa
jeunesse reportage d'hervé dino et
thierry zac ultime tour de piste pour
lucien jeunesse mais avant de tirer sa
révérence il lance une dernière fois sa
formule magique cherche un vivons jour
[Applaudissements]
depuis 50 ans il foule les planches au
music hall et au théâtre d'abord puis à
partir de 1965 pour les tournées du jeu
des mille francs une émission qui lui
colle à la peau
mais aujourd'hui l'heure de la retraite
a tintinnabuler une drogue que je
risquais de données intoxiqués c'est
pourquoi j'ai préféré lever le pied pour
essayer de faire autre chose et pour
surtout pouvoir respirer un peu prendre
des vacances que je n'ai jamais puisque
lorsque nous ont détourné c'est en
actuellement quinze jours mais ce fut
longtemps une ville par jour et cela
nous amène à une question digne du super
banco il a séjourné dans une chambre
d'hôtel a pris vingt mille repas au
restaurant a passé quarante mille coups
de téléphone à son épouse pour rendre la
séparation plus douce qui est il lucien
jeunesse évidemment véritable vrp du jeu
radiophonique durant trente années il
s'est prêté aux questions des
journalistes a posé en compagnie du
maire de la ville des genêts avec les
pouces du maire sélectionner les
candidats et enfin signer des chèques
aux heureux gagnants
lucien jeunesse qui affiche 71 printemps
ne sillonnera plus la france pourrait
toucher la mézière sous le regard de sa
femme à qui il se consacrera entièrement
désormais il n'a pu se résoudre à dire
adieu à demain si vous voulez bien
[Musique]